how has the past year been i know that's
a huge question i understand there's a
lot
going on but have you been hopefully
feeling
kind of happier than not over this past
year how's it been for you
um yeah i think uh i don't know i think
generally you know
uh i don't know it's it's been
obviously an unprecedented year so
strange
um just trying to it's definitely
perspective
altering um just trying to stay safe you
know
and uh you know
i don't know stay in contact with loved
ones and try to get some work done and
uh i don't know yeah about you
i mean it's been all right it's it's
been a lot of this obviously right like
like kind of hanging out and getting to
chat with people and that's sort of yeah
yeah you're at your home is this like
your setup this is my setup yeah
yeah this is how it goes do you have any
pants on right now
i do i have no shoes or socks or jackets
but i am
yeah just this is just this is not even
a real shirt it's just like a
mascot thing yeah no sleeves to cut off
yeah that's it
exactly um i wonder if you were
working on your drawing skills at all
while you're at home because in the
trailer
i don't want to say anything bad about
the drawing that you do of jessica and
the trailer for the movie
mine is lovely it's lovely but
have you been working on drawing at all
no
no i'm uh i'm a terrible drawer
that was that the the sketch um
was originally supposed to be really
good and i just thought it would be
funny
well i thought it'd be funny and also
just like really nice
um for you to see how he starts off he's
not that good you know
it's kind of funny and then and then
like you know he cherishes this gift
so much that then you see his progress
down the line and he actually gets like
quite good at it you know
yeah um i don't know but so i we did a
we did a version we didn't end up using
it but like i actually just drew one
because i'm such a horrendous
i can't draw a campaign it's like it's
like um
i have no ability to do anything of the
such like
stick figures are literally like the
extent of what i can pull off
so i was like let me draw her face for
real so like me jess went to her trailer
i remember
and i was like sketching her uh and we
we shot it we didn't use it we ended up
using it
we had like the onset like one of the
artists on set you know
um make up like a bad one and it was
funny here so
but mine was horrendous yeah we got to
we got to see it someday
someone's got a someone's got to have
that yeah i should i should have like a
picture of it or something
there's no way i'm going to dive into it
now can we use the rest of the seven
minutes for me just
specific do you want to just sketch me
while you're while we're waiting like we
can do that too do you want to do that
for the rest of the interview
i mean personally yes but i don't know
if anybody else wants to see that
it would be shocked it's like truly
shocking how untalented of a
of a sketch artist i am it's unreal
well i mean at least you got this acting
thing to fall back on which seems to be
doing pretty well for you right now
yeah yeah yeah until people figure it
out
i'm a fake this the other thing i was
really curious about too is like we see
a lot of at least in the trailer we see
a lot of you
kind of outdoors and you're running and
jumping away from like
imaginary monsters throwing like toy hot
dogs whatever
what is that like for you to be out
there and
like do you see a sketch of this monster
before you're imagining running away
from some giant
octopus mucus thing or what yeah yeah
yeah they i mean
yeah it's it's a it's this big funny
dance really you know so like
yeah definitely the the vfx team who
just got nominated for an oscar by the
way
everybody congratulations
congratulations
um so cool truly so cool um
so yeah those guys like they always you
know they have like uh
these renderings on their computers
they're always there uh matt sloane our
vfx supervisor why i'd actually like
worked with uh before
too um he's always
uh you know it's kind of a dance between
the vfx team
and the director um and then them sort
of showing me like what the action is
and what it's gonna look like and
as much as they can show me which they
they have like a lot done
um um so they we go and i look i get a
look
uh we kind of communicate on like the
size of the thing and just
like things like that and then it's just
yeah and then i don't know you're just
sort of like
orchestrating the the action with the
like you know like the acting i don't
know it's just like it's just fun it's
funny it's weird it's like
it's like what's fun about acting you
know it's all it's it's totally like
your imagination so it's uh um i don't
know i enjoy doing that stuff
it's hilarious because you are just
reacting to nothing
so this is funny you know we've seen you
in like
action films for years and obviously
when you're in the middle of doing
something you have an idea of what it
might look like when you're done but
like are you still when you watch
something back
and you see all the effects and
everything put in are you still blown
away by what you guys have
to accomplish oh totally yeah of course
it's amazing
um it's one of the funnest parts you
know um
getting to see how it comes out it's
never um it's never like totally how you
imagined it it's always like
you know the detail that goes into these
things
are so incredible you know um there's
such little cool details on these
monsters that i
i even just like found out about uh just
seeing some clips and stuff like
um you know there's like on the crab
there's like this i didn't even notice
that on one of the legs they put like
this
trap that's now tiny because it's just
on one of his little legs you know
but that was like his trap that he
initially when he mutated he broke out
of like stuff like that you know it's so
cool
uh and to see how they move and um
you know it really fills out the worlds
uh
and it really elevates it you know and
that and the monsters are obviously
always going to be a big part of this
movie
um it's so funny to read the script and
picture doing this type of movie live
action you know a boy with a dog
running through this monster apocalypse
it's totally like animated
so it was really cool to try to and
nearly impossible to like try to do it
live action and i just think it's so
cool
like i'm so proud of it i can't believe
we pulled it off and it's like i don't
know it's just really fun it's really
fun to see it come all together and
it's really cool to see the vfx team uh
get acknowledged too i mean that's like
i mean what a cool thing you know all
right for sure now obviously you're top
line here but are you ready to play
second fiddle to this dog like this dog
is adorable
yeah i know he's the star of the movie
he's completely the star of the movie i
knew the whole time too
it's such a competitive thing you know
the whole movie i was like
you think you're better than me
[Laughter]
uh hiro and dodge and zaylee their
trainer were
truly one of like the most special parts
of the experience for me
and uh i fell in love with them and
their whole family and
um we still talk and hopefully i'll get
to
go and see them all again one day
and yeah it was i don't know it's just
like the flattest co-star you can
possibly have no knock to any of my
coasters i've ever had who i
loved and i'm very close with many of
them but hero i mean my god
i don't usually cuddle with my co-stars
like on set you know what i mean that's
not usually yes yeah i can't like get on
the ground and be like
you know and start cuddling you know
that out of out of this entire interview
what we're going to take out is you
shading
all your other co-stars because you're
talking about how your dog is
i was curious i want to ask you about uh
the whole stunt thing because
since your recovery and it's you've been
busy since you've been back
um but do do you feel hesitation when it
comes to doing some things or are you
like
what goes through your head when you're
now
getting into those sorts of scenes or
having to do those sorts of things
uh yeah it'll always be different you
know um
in a good way i think at this point i've
come out of it in a really good
way i've spoken about it a lot you know
this is uh
um it's it's you know it's it's
something that
like has shaped uh how i always think of
things and it's really it's nice because
otherwise you know
you have to protect yourself in ways and
everything you do you know and on set
um uh i think that's like a that's
totally like a lesson that
i don't know young actors go all go
through their own sort of ways of
learning that uh you sort of have to
look out for yourself um but this was
you know these
these stunts i mean it's always been
something that i love to do
it's so much fun and it's um and it's so
much a part of like what you're doing
and
you know what the movie is and um it
brings it to life you know and
um yeah it's really cool i know i
i i still enjoy it always will
that's awesome yeah it's great to see
you doing those things
like it's it's just it's so cool man um
one thing that we're also i know i'm
excited for
is you having worked with antoine fukua
and mark wahlberg
on infinite is there something is there
anything you can tell us about that
uh yeah do you want me to just
like spill what the movie is that'd be
hilarious yeah just just tell us the
ending
dude um
yeah well what can i tell you i mean
it's like uh you know it's this like big
sci-fi
um original like sci-fi high concept
kind of big action movie um
it's cool it's weird it's uh i think
it'll be
uh interesting i haven't seen any of it
normally in it that
much as well that's the thing but yeah
we're good with the anton and like
um i didn't get to really work with mark
again but i got to see him again uh
obviously i've worked with him
in the past you know he's always been
super nice to me and uh
uh yeah it was just a fun um fight
coordinator in that movies uh
uh someone that i really loved working
with it was just a fun
um um thing to be a part of and uh fun
fun sequence to do and
um yeah i'm looking forward to seeing it
it's one of those things where
it's been so long now i think they've
done their entire post-production like
during this quarantine which you know
must be
absolute hell yeah well i mean
we've seen projects come together during
this time and
it's an exciting thing to look forward
to for sure i'm looking forward to that
one as well thanks so much for this time
management
hey dude good to meet you
you